ADAM SKOLNICK: Dean's Blue Hole.
Long Island, Bahamas.
November 17th, 2013.
The warm Atlantic sloshed
in Nicholas Mobley's ears
as he floated into
the competition zone
at Dean's Blue Hole.
He looked calm, but
appearances can be deceiving.
When Vertical Blue
kicked off, he
had ambitions for a bronze medal
and two more American records.
Yet after a year of
intense preparation,
and winning an overall gold
in another competition only
weeks earlier, plus silver at
the world championship a month
before that, he proceeded
to flub every single dive
that week.
This was the Wimbledon
of freediving.
Aside from Worlds, it was
the only competition that
mattered to him and most
others in the sport,
and Nick was out of juice.
Every muscle in his body hurt.
Even his lungs hurt.
But he wasn't about to give up.
It was game day and
he was preparing
to descend to 72
meters, or 240 feet,
and back on a single breath.
Six minutes, announced
Sam Trubridge,
a theater director
from Auckland,
New Zealand, and the older
brother of William Trubridge,
the greatest
freediver of them all.
Standing on the
platform, Sam loomed
over Nick, who lay on his back
clipped to the competition
line.
His eyes stayed mostly closed,
but when he opened them,
they flashed with focus
and determination.
The competition
zone was delineated
by a set of white PVC pipes
that formed a six meter
square within the
dark blue of the hole.
Inside were a photographer, a
videographer, and three judges,
including lead
judge Grant Graves,
one of the longest tenured
professionals in the sport.
Also within the zone were
five safety divers, clad
in long bi-fins led
by Nick's friend
Ren Chapman, a former
college baseball
star from Wilmington,
North Carolina.
It was the safety divers job to
meet the athletes once they'd
reached a depth of 30
meters while ascending
from their dive.
That's where pressure
underwater shifts,
and where lactic acid build up,
and hypoxia, or lack of oxygen,
can begin to cause problems.
Clinging to the
floating boundaries
were a handful of fans and
several of Nick's rivals.
Folks like Mike Board,
44, the UK record holder,
and a former royal marine.
Half Chinese, half-English,
six feet tall and all muscle.
Mike patrolled the infamous
Baghdad Airport Road
as a private military
contractor during the Iraq war.
And earned good money
dodging suicide attacks
and ferrying high dollar
clients to the safety
of the green zone.
Afterwards he used his earnings
to build a flourishing freedive
center in Indonesia's Gili
islands, which enabled
him to train year round.
In terms of global
standing within the sport,
Mike and Nick were among the
elite national record holders,
and both hoped to be contending
for a world record soon.
Also in the water
was Junko Kitahama,
another national record
holder from Japan.
She watched him carefully.
Their conversation on
the beach had thrown her,
and she was worried.
Five minutes.
So were his friends and family.
They were aware that
Nick was hurting,
and they also knew that
when others took breaks,
he doubled down on training.
While many kept a less
ambitious competition schedule,
Nick Mobley took every
opportunity to dive.
That's what made him the best
American freediver in less
than two years of competition.
But mulling past victories
wasn't going to help him now.
Frustrated, he
clenched his eyes tight
to silence his brain speak.
To switch off and calm down.
He took a cleansing
breath and leaned back.
Submerging his face, stimulating
the nerves around his eyes,
and sparking the
mammalian dive reflex,
a physiological response
that, if developed,
helped an average
man become Aquaman.
Capable of freediving
to unheard of depths
for minutes at a
time, without feeling
any anxiety, or the
slightest urge to breathe.
Four minutes.
He inhaled long and slow
and exhaled twice as slow,
twice as calm.
Each time purging his system
of negativity and carbon
dioxide, the buildup of which
spurs that urge to breathe
and can turn a relaxed, peaceful
adventure into excruciating
toil.
If a stray bolt of fear
bloomed in his mind,
he'd slow its breath
down even more.
That was the only way
to lower his heart rate
and keep his demons at bay.
Three minutes.
He knew them well, his demons.
They had trailed
him his entire life.
They fueled him.
His broken home.
His feelings of inadequacy.
His frustration with a society
attuned to greed and waste,
what drove him into the
water in the first place.
They also blessed him
with uncommon generosity.
On land, Nick wasn't the fierce
competitor he was on the line.
And beneath all of that anxiety,
pain and loss, brain chatter,
and sea water
sloshing in his ears,
he knew something else, too.
He had one more
dive left in him,
and he was going
to tear that Velcro
tag from the bottom plate, come
up clean, and claim his record.
Two minutes.
He visualized the dive.
Something his friend
William Trubridge,
a 15 time world record holder,
and owner of Vertical Blue,
taught him when
they roomed together
during the Caribbean Cup in
Honduras, the previous May.
Where Nick made the
dive of his life,
and became the first American
to swim the 100 meters
on a single breath.
He used a monofin that day.
On Sunday, November
17th, he would
dive without fins, which
ratcheted up the difficulty
several degrees.
Will stood on the beach,
barefoot as usual,
watching Nick breathe up.
Typically he stayed away from
the hole when he wasn't diving,
but he didn't miss Nick's dives.
Nobody in the history of the
sport had gotten to 100 meters
so fast, and Will knew he was
witnessing someone special.
Someone capable of breaking
world records one day.
And going deeper than
any human had before.
One minute.
As the clock ticked
below 30 seconds,
Nick's breathing
pattern changed,
and he began sipping
the air, attempting
to fill his lungs to the limit.
From the depth of his
diaphragm to those
little used air pockets between
and behind the shoulder blades.
And in so doing,
pack as much oxygen
into his system as possible.
He would need it.
If all went according to plan
he wouldn't breathe again
for nearly three minutes.
Dean's Blue Hole bloomed
out of the freediving scene
in 2005, when Will began
living and training there.
At the time, he was not yet
a champion, but an aspirant.
Frustrated by the
lack of accessibility
to deep water and
good conditions
on a consistent basis.
He found both on
Long Island, Bahamas,
and within a few short years
he became one of the best,
if not the best
freediver on earth.
Freedivers soon flocked
to train alongside him,
and those that were
instructors, brought students.
That's how Nick
found it in 2012,
when he was about to come
out of nowhere to break
his first American record.
81 miles long, but less than
four miles across at its widest
point, Long Island is
splayed like a twisted egg
noodle between the
frothing blue Atlantic
Ocean, and the placid
turquoise Caribbean Sea.
Etched from limestone
by wind, surf, and rain,
its stubby hills and
plains are blanketed
in thick tropical scrub.
Rustling with wild
boar and feral cats.
Stitched with mangroves,
and blessed with a series
of exquisite virgin beaches.
On his maiden voyage in
1492, Christopher Columbus
navigated the northern
tip of Long Island.
He named it
Fernandina, anchoring
on the Caribbean
side of what became
known as Cape Santa Maria.
A single strip of
asphalt leads from there
towards the southern terminus.
And after about an hour's
drive, in the town of Deans,
a gravel and dirt road branches
east over low lying hills
and around a bend to Will's
beloved Blue Hole, where
the wind is almost
always muffled,
and the current ever gentle,
even in stormy weather.
That's because it's sheltered
by a concave semicircle
of thick limestone that
rises over 50 feet high.
It's insides, grooved with
giant primordial brushstrokes,
are drilled with shallow
caves and punctuated
by phallic stalactites that
dangle over a sea so dark blue,
it has no business
being just three
steps from a silky
white sand beach, where
Will stood watching.
As the clock wound down
on Nicholas Mobley.
Sam ticked off the seconds.
10.
Nine.
Eight.
When he got to zero,
Nick submerged face first
with his arms extended.
He looked like a human arrow
shooting into the darkness.
Dean's Blue Hole is an
underwater cavern flip
vertically, shaped
like a carafe.
As Nick swam, he
passed a rugged reef
which sprouted from
sloping white sand that
led to a ring of sheer limestone
10 meters below the surface.
He'd reached the rim
of the hole, where
sand spilled over the edge in
a series of mesmerizing sand
falls that look exactly like a
photo negative of a waterfall.
Within five powerful
breast strokes,
those cliff walls receded
beneath a sloped ceiling,
where small schools of giant
tarpon or silver barracuda,
often hunkered in the shadows.
After another few strokes,
and another 10 meter drop,
there was a second
set of cliffs,
and the walls receded again.
Soon the hole was
darker than midnight,
and about twice as
wide as the entire cove
appears from the surface.
The rim of the hole has
a 35 meter diameter.
Below 20 meters, the
diameter is estimated
at more than 150 meters.
Nick had stopped
swimming by then.
His arms at his side,
his chin tucked,
he became as
streamlined as possible.
It was time to freefall.
The part of a dive that
feels like floating
through outer space.
He closed his eyes
and surrendered
to the soft slow
sink into dream time.
[APPLAUSE]
That's how the book starts.
And I was at the
Blue Hole that day.
I was there covering Vertical
Blue, the competition,
for the "New York
Times" sports page.
It's a roundabout
way how i got there,
but I was there just to
do a mid-week feature.
There wasn't even really a firm
deadline on the assignment,
it was going to
run at some point
during the football
playoffs, they were
going to have this feature.
And when Nick died, obviously it
became something else entirely.
Became breaking news story
for a couple of days,
and ended up all over the world.
It went crazy viral.
Because people are
interested in the sport,
interested in what
freediving is, I think.
Not just because it's extreme,
but because it's something
that we've all tried to do.
So I thought, when Ben
and I met last year,
and then he started
working here,
I just thought it was a
really great opportunity,
we both did, to talk
about it because it's
a captivating sport
where people are doing
things we've all tried to do.
Hold our breath as
long as possible,
and maybe swim the
length of a pool,
or kick down when we're
snorkeling to a reef.
And here are people going
deeper than scuba divers can
go with a tank.
Much deeper.
It's not even close.
And they're doing
it on one breath.
So I thought we'd talk a little
bit about what freediving is.
And Ben can help with
that since he's as much
a freediver as a Googler.
BEN: That's true.
I've been freediving
for about eight years
now, and then scuba diving
for probably eight years
before that.
It is a very intellectual sport.
You have to do a lot of fine
tuning, and a lot of thinking.
It's mind over matter to
do some of these things
that you need to do freediving.
I tried, at first,
to teach myself.
I was scuba diving
a lot, and then
on the last day of
a scuba trip you're
not supposed to dive
and fly on the same day.
So I would go out and snorkel
some of the same reefs,
and see something
30, 40, 50 feet down,
that I wanted to
go take a look at.
And I'd try to go down,
and I'd get 20 feet down
and feel like I had to breathe,
and have to turn around.
My ears would hurt.
It was something where there
was more to it than that.
I knew that some people were
able to do really amazing stuff
underwater, and I really
wanted to figure that out.
So when the dive shop that
I do my scuba diving with,
Malibu Divers, hosted a
freediving course, just
a weekend course with an outfit
called Performance Freediving,
I signed up for that.
And in one weekend I
doubled my breath hold time,
and I doubled my depth I was
able to get to in the ocean,
and just got completely hooked.
And so from that
intermediate course,
then I went onto
an advanced course,
and from there went on to do
some local competitions, which
eventually led to
joining the US team.
And I competed in the
world championships in 2010
through 2012.
After that was a safety diver
for various competitions,
especially at Vertical Blue.
I was a safety
diver in 2011, 2012.
I actually was supposed to
go 2013, and I missed it.
So I was not there when the
incident with Nick happened.
But I was there in
2014, the year after,
where the safety was suddenly
taken just amazingly seriously.
And we had a
wonderful safety team.
Grant Graves is
here, by the way.
He was the head judge for a
lot of these competitions,
and has been part of the
sport for a very long time.
Probably the most experienced
freediving judge and expert
that there is.
Also Tank [INAUDIBLE]
is here, who
was a friend of Nick's and
an Australian national record
holder.
So they could take questions
at some point as well.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
I think, to set up
what the sport is,
and what he's talking about,
I think it's important.
Who here has tried to hold
their breath in the pool
as long as possible?
And who has tried to swim from
one end of the pool and back,
on a single breath?
And either done it, or not?
Everybody.
It's this universal
human activity.
And freediving has been
going on for millennia.
Even though there's this
growing popularity that
has happened, ancient
Greek and ancient Rome,
they had these early underwater
Navy SEAL team type things
that they deploy, and they would
build underwater barricades.
They're sponge divers.
Pearl divers.
Spear fisherman.
People still live
off of spear fishing
in Indonesia, and Africa,
and in the Mediterranean.
All over the world.
This is something
humans have always
been able to do, and have used.
What competitive freediving--
that started in the '40s.
And originally, the
competition was using weights
to get down as deep as possible.
So it was always
who's the deepest?
Who's the deepest?
And often, they
would be weighted,
they would drop weights,
and they would swim back.
That's a discipline that
we call variable weight
now in competitive freediving.
The competitive
freediving that we
depict in this book,
which is really,
these are the six
events that are
used in competitive freediving.
There's three that
are in the pool.
There's static, which is holding
your breath as long as you can,
face down in a pool.
The world record is 11
minutes and 54 seconds.
That's pretty long.
The second is
dynamic, which you're
wearing a monofin, which are
those dolphin like tail fins
with two feet in one fin.
And dynamic, that
record I think is still
281 meters, right? [INAUDIBLE].
And then there's dynamic with
no fins, which is the same idea.
Trying to go as
long as possible,
not as deep as
possible, from one
the end of the pool and back.
And you do as long as
possible without fins.
And that's a breast stroke.
And again they're under water.
They're weighted
with their neck,
so they are not
allowed to eclipse
the surface of the water.
That's what Tank was
so good at as well.
The pool disciplines.
But pool disciplines are also
training for the deep divers.
The reason you want to build
up your static, as a diver,
is if you hold your breath for,
say, five minutes in static,
or at the surface, you can
swim for 2 and 1/2 minutes
on one breath, down below.
And that's the simple formula.
And so you want to develop
that static ability
if you want to dive deep.
And same with dynamic, because
you're training your body
to withstand lactic
acid build up,
and carbon dioxide buildup
in your body, and so
the deep divers do
the pool for training.
But the three disciplines
in deep freediving
are constant weight.
They call it constant
weight because any weight
you bring down with you,
you have to bring back up.
But constant weight
is with a monofin.
And that record is 128 meters,
held by Alexey Molchanov
and Will Trubridge has
the two other world
records on the men's side.
And those are with
free immersion.
Which is, you pull down
on a line down to depth,
and then you pull
back to the surface.
No fins.
And then constant no
fins, which is what Nick
was doing when he passed away.
And that record is 101 meters,
and that's a modified breast
stroke down and back.
The free immersion
record's 121 meters.
On the women's side,
it was dominated
by Alexey Molchanov's mother,
Natalia Molchanova who
was the most decorated athlete
in the history of the sport.
The greatest female
freediver of all time.
Has every single record.
And she passed away last year.
And she passed away in
a very different way
than what happened with Nick.
What happened with Nick
was-- and it obviously
gets into the book--
he was diving injured.
And then he went down and came
back on his own at the surface.
And appeared to be
breathing for a full minute
before he blacked out.
Blacking out is
not that uncommon
in competitive freediving.
It doesn't happen a
majority of the time,
at all, but in
competitive freediving,
especially at places like
Vertical Blue and the world
championships, where people are
really pushing their limits,
and the pressure is high,
you can use your oxygen
store prematurely,
even if you've
trained to a certain level.
People do blackout.
And that's why there are
safety divers around.
And because of the
physics of freediving,
you're not going to
black out of depth.
It's always when you're coming
back towards the surface,
or at the surface.
90% of freedivers will
black out at the surface.
9% of them will be
shallower than 10 meters.
And less than 1%
will be below that.
But the safety divers will
swim down to about 30,
or sometimes even 40
meters, to meet a diver,
and swim back with them
on the way back up.
That's why there are
safety divers there.
And people do get
blackout underwater,
and they're brought up, and
they come around right away.
But usually, you're
going to black out
in the first or second
breath at the surface.
And Nick didn't.
And so, what happened to
Nick is something nobody
had ever seen before in
the history of the sport.
What happened with
Natalia was something
that happens to something like
100 spear fisherman every year.
She was diving virtually alone.
The people that she
had been diving with
were not equipped to safety her.
She got caught in an underwater
current, and came up,
and blacked out, shallow water,
and they never found her.
So that's more like how
a lot of spear fisherman
do pass away doing this sport.
It's not because of
the extreme of depth,
it's because they're holding
their breath a little bit too
long.
Maybe they've done too many
dives that day, they're tired,
could be any number of reasons.
But there's nobody
there to protect them.
The blackout itself
is not dangerous,
it's blacking out alone
that is so dangerous.
But with Nick's
story, it's different.
That's what made it such
an interesting story
to write about.
You start with his death and you
go back through his life story.
And his life story is
so interesting, too.
And then you get back
and forth from 2013
to the 2014 freediving
season, where
the whole sport has changed.
And we're trying to figure
out what happened to Nick,
and what the sport can do.
And that's when Ben and I met
in Vertical Blue that next year.
I just wanted to give you
guys the whole picture
of what this competitive
freediving world is all about.
Competitive freediving
is just one aspect of it.
It's also just recreational.
So anywhere that you
might go scuba diving
in the world, where there's
a bunch of scuba centers,
there's also now
freediving centers
popping up all over the world.
Do we know how fast it's
grown in the last few years?
It's just grown exponentially.
I know that.
Are there numbers
on that, at all?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM SKOLNICK: Tripled.
And then also PADI, which is
the scuba diving association,
they now have
certification body.
Now they have a freediving
curriculum, too.
So it just shows you
that as it's growing.
And some of those
hobbyists become athletes.
Before I turn back to Ben, one
thing about these competitions
is, they're kind of like
the triathlons would be,
or runs would be.
There's weekend
warriors that are just
trying to get their own personal
best a little bit better,
and they're serious about it.
But they're not real contenders.
Then there's the national record
holders and the world record
holders.
But what's unique
about this sport is,
if you are a world
record holder,
you might also have to be the
guy blocking off the roads
if you are a triathlete.
Imagine the best triathlete
in the world blocking off
the roads in Kona
before the Iron Man.
That's basically what
these guys are doing.
They're elite, elite athletes.
In my opinion, the
best of them are
on par with Olympic swimmers.
That's the athletic ability
we're talking about here.
You can always tell when
an elite freedivers is
in the room, it looks
like an elite athlete.
Covering athletes like
I have, you can tell.
That's how I feel about it.
And that's the sport.
BEN: I was just going
to mention something
a little counter-intuitive about
freediving in the ocean, which
is that for most people, the
limiting factor in how deep you
can go is not about breath hold.
I think that it
would seem intuitive
that it's about how long
you can hold your breath,
and the longer you can hold your
breath, the deeper you can go.
But actually, adapting to
the pressure as you go down
is really the limiting
factor for most people.
And through most of the
history of the sport,
everyone figured out,
mostly for themselves,
how to go about
acclimating to the pressure
as they went deeper,
and figuring out tricks
to get deeper.
And that changed a few years
ago when some people developed
techniques that were
more teachable for how
to use certain tricks to get
down to depth a lot quicker.
And so suddenly beginners
were able to use
these techniques to go
much deeper than they
were really ready for.
And I think that's gone over
extensively in the book.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah, it is.
And we should talk a little
bit about what the appeal is.
Why would you?
If it's just an ego trip,
what's the point of writing
a book about this
group of weirdos
that are trying to go
as deep as possible,
just for their own ego trip.
That's not what this is.
I like to talk about what
happens on the dive itself,
to give you an idea of
why these athletes want
to dive over and over again.
When you start at the
surface-- actually
an athlete will prepare
to dive for up to an hour
before the dive itself.
And they'll just relax
as deeply as possible.
Get the heart rate down
as slow as possible.
Because the breath that
they're going to take,
that peak inhalation where
they will fill their lungs,
and then they'll continue to
pack air, and use their tongue
as a piston, to push more
air down into their lungs,
so they over inflate their
lungs, some of them up to 20%
above their normal lug capacity.
They're doing that, and
that's their oxygen tank.
That's all the
oxygen they've got.
We all know, oxygen
is how our cells work.
That's our fuel.
That's all they've got
to get down and back.
And then they'll kick.
And you have to kick hard
to get down, because you're
dealing with positive buoyancy.
We've all done that.
We've all tried to kicked
down and you're like, whoa,
I'm not getting anywhere.
And they have to kick hard.
Till about neutral buoyancy.
And it depends on
how they're weighted,
but it's around 10 meters.
And then they can kick
softer, and they'll
continue to go down.
And after 20, 25 meters,
they'll stop kicking altogether.
And they will start sinking.
That's that freefall.
And they'll sink at
about a meter per second.
So this slow, soft, sink.
And most will just
close their eyes
and surrender to it, because
thoughts also burn oxygen.
So you want to keep
that brain blank.
And then the physiological
hacks start coming in,
and that's what is known as
the mammalian dive reflex.
And it's called that because
that's how seals and sea
lions dive deep, too.
The same thing can
happen in the human body.
And a few things that happen
is that the veins and arteries
in your arms and legs constrict,
and it floods the blood
to your core, because your
lungs are also compressing.
At the surface we have
100% of our lung capacity.
At 10 meters, because
of barometric pressure,
we have half that lung capacity.
20 meters, it's a third, and so
on, all the way down the line,
till your lungs are the
size of a tennis ball.
And so that blood starts to
engorge the pulmonary arteries,
the veins in your
core, and that,
also, contributes to a
reduction in heart rate.
About half your
resting heart rate.
So we're talking
about elite athletes.
So they're going to be
in the 50's probably,
so now, all of a sudden,
you're having a heart rate
in the 20's and 30's
as you sink down.
And that's something
that's really only
been recorded in Buddhist
monks in the laboratory.
That's the level
we're getting at.
And so then they keep
sinking, they keep sinking.
And if you go super deep,
nitrogen narcosis can pop in.
Which is, if you've ever
scuba dove, and you've
gone to any depth,
you might feel that.
And it's like this psychedelic
thing that's happening.
They're super relaxed,
their heart rates down,
they get to the bottom
plate, they pull the tag,
and they have to kick back
against that negative buoyancy.
That pressure that has shifted,
and it's started sinking down,
now they have to kick
back against that,
which is like kicking
through a swift current.
And they've already
been underwater
for half the amount of
time they're planning,
and so now's the time to kick.
And that's the athletic portion.
So now they're kicking
hard, they're kicking hard,
they're kicking hard.
And as they get
back to the surface,
and if they can get
back to the surface
under their own power,
which is almost every time,
they take that first
breath, all of a sudden
that endorphin rush comes on.
So you've had this psychedelic
spiritual experience augmented
by this endorphin rush, and
it's a euphoric, exhilarating
experience, obviously.
It's this feeling that vibrate
your body and your mind.
And it's why people
are addicted to it.
And it's why people,
like Nick, or like Ben,
you feel that one time.
Or even a beginner like me,
when I first started doing this,
it took 15 instructors to get
me down to a decent depth.
I ended up getting to 100 feet.
But I remember this one
time when I went down
to about 50 feet,
and all of a sudden I
didn't have to
breathe at that point.
I didn't have to go up,
I didn't have to breathe.
I was so comfortable.
And for the rest of the day,
every time I'd close my eyes,
I'd see that blue world.
When divers go even
deeper than that,
when they're below 50 meters,
time slows down even more.
Often it feels like the
sea is squeezing them,
and they become just a
speck of consciousness
in this vast abyss.
And it's all part
of that allure.
That's why people do this.
Because it's a
beautiful experience
you can only get this way.
And I think that's really
important because not only are
they great athletes--
like you said,
it's this intellectual problem.
It's a problem that
continually needs to be solved.
You talked about
limiting factors.
Maybe you can talk about
how everyone might have
a different limiting factor.
And how you try to
always solve the equation
of going a little bit deeper.
BEN: Sure.
Some of it can be
psychological, where
you can get down
to a certain depth,
then suddenly have the thought
of I'm 100 feet under water,
and you freak out
and turn around.
There's various
physiological aspects
that can kick in
the urge to breathe,
even if you have plenty
of oxygen. So overcoming
some of those limitations.
Just getting to that point
where you can just relax and not
fight against the pressure
that's pushing on you,
takes a while to get calm
enough to adapt to that.
I will second the fact that
the freefall stage, when you've
kicked down 50, 60, 70 feet,
and you can just start sinking
is just completely addictive.
Probably the same way that
freefall would be in skydiving.
And so being able to get
to the point-- and it
takes quite a bit of
work to get to the point
where you're going deep
enough to experience that,
but it really is magical.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
And it takes reps, also.
Life is reps, in my opinion.
Life is reps.
You need to have the reps.
You need to get in the water.
You need to do it over and over.
The more you do it, the more
you love it, kind of thing.
I think that's how I would
put it, don't you think?
BEN: Sure.
It is.
And when you've been out
of the water for a while
and you go back into it, usually
the first day or two or three,
you have to start much
shallower than you
were doing the last time.
When I'm at my
peak in freediving,
I've been down
close to 70 meters,
but when I start off on a
dive trip the first day,
I'll go to maybe 30 meters.
And that will feel
like a lot of work,
because my body has
not adapted to it yet.
And so it can be depressing
the first day on a dive trip.
But usually it comes
back fairly quickly.
And then pacing yourself
to reach your limits again.
Yeah, for these guys like
William Trubridge who
lives at the Blue Hole and
trains there 11 months out
of the year, or
trains freediving
a huge amount of the
time, he can just
adapt to the point
of going-- I mean,
he has he's been down
over 120 meters, which is
almost double what I've done.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah
, but 67 is no joke.
67 meters is 200
feet plus, right?
BEN: 220.
ADAM SKOLNICK: 220.
That's heavy duty.
BEN: On the breath hold
front, my deepest dive,
which was 67 meters-- it took
about a minute and 15 seconds
on the way down, and about 50
seconds on the way back up.
So the whole dive time
was just over two minutes.
So a dive like that is really
less about breath hold,
and more about just
adapting to the pressure.
I felt comfortable on that
dive all the way to the bottom.
I think I could have
gone a little deeper.
And that's the other
aspect of the sport.
Once you successfully make
a dive to your-- especially
if it's a personal best-- and
you come back and you think,
oh I could have gone just a
tiny bit deeper than that,
and that drives you to just--
ADAM SKOLNICK: Right.
And it's a brain loop, right?
So that's what I think another
interesting point of the book
is.
Where Nick was a perfect
example of what a lot of divers
feel is, no dive is good enough.
There's always another
dive out there.
Some just crunch numbers.
William Trubridge is
a perfect example.
He'll stare at his computer
and his dive profiles
for hours to try to
edge out another meter.
Because it's part of
this self feeding loop.
With Nick it was a
little self-destructive.
There's a lot of reasons that
what happened that day-- there
were about eight
or nine things that
could have gone differently.
Some of them were in Nick's
control, some of them were not.
And that's what makes
it-- any sort of tragedy,
whether it's a plane
crash or anything else,
often you hear that.
Eight or nine things went wrong.
Not one thing.
And with the Nick's death,
that's certainly true.
But Nick's life was
really rich as well.
He came from a broken home.
The great story is
when he was a year
and a half old, his family
dog pushed him in the pool,
and his grandmother went
looking around for him,
and saw him at the
bottom the pool.
And he had his cheeks
puffed out, his eyes open,
with a smile on his face.
And his grandmother
saw him down there,
he was perfectly comfortable.
And as parents started
fighting as he was growing up,
he'd hold the ladder
in the family pool,
and hold himself down until
the fighting had subsided.
The water was always
his safe place.
It was always where he'd go
for calmness and serenity.
As he grew up, he was
a great BMX rider.
He was going to try out for
the X-Games before an injury.
He ends up in Philadelphia
in 2000 for the GOP National
Convention, when
it was basically
everyone went from
the Battle of Seattle
to the Philadelphia Convention.
So he's with the
same people that were
working in the WTO protests.
And he was doing that.
From there, he met a woman,
and moved to New York
to try to be an actor in film.
He wrote and directed his
own film with his girlfriend.
He ended up in Williamsburg
right after 9/11,
right before Williamsburg
became a thing.
When he got to
Williamsburg, Brooklyn,
the downstairs bar
at his apartment
is where you went to get coke.
That's where the
New York cops went
to do coke on their off hours.
And he'd see them
come in and out.
So he was in Williamsburg when
it was still totally derelict.
And then he ends up
working in production,
and one of his first
jobs in production
was to work on a
show that was a DC
comic that people hadn't really
heard of yet, Dave Chapelle.
And so he was on the
whole Chapelle Show run.
His life, all the way up
until the point of him
discovering freediving
is interesting.
And so it weaves in and out.
And it talks about
his pull to the sport.
But it also profiles
the other athletes
that you saw in the
video, Natalia included.
That's why I wanted to
talk to you guys about it.
Because it's a sport people
don't know that much about,
but it's something
that we can all do.
I swim in the ocean a
lot, so I love the ocean.
And I've done some tech
diving and scuba diving.
But when it came
to freediving, it
was harder for me to do
than I thought it would be.
I mean, I'm in the ocean like
four to five days a week,
but when it came
to freediving, it's
a different type of experience.
And it takes a
different attention,
and different mechanics, but
when you do it, you feel it.
BEN: You feel like a dolphin.
When you get to the point
where you can dive down 50,
60 feet and just be
comfortable down there
for an extended amount of time,
then you feel like a superhero.
Aquaman, right?
ADAM SKOLNICK: You are.
I'm not.
BEN: Yeah.
There's some places--
ADAM SKOLNICK: I'm
beginner Aquaman.
These guys are real Aquamen.
BEN: One of my
favorite places to dive
is a spot called
Honaunau Bay, that's
near Kona on the Big
Island of Hawaii.
And it's where the spinner
dolphins come in during the day
to go to sleep.
And they swim in these big
circles around the Bay.
And if you're out
there freediving,
you can anticipate by
watching where they are, when
they're going to get to you.
And so 20 or 30 seconds
before they get there you
can go and swim down 20 meters,
and just hover in the water
and wait for them.
And you'll see this entire pod
of spinner dolphins come out
of the blue at you.
And the little baby
dolphins want to play,
and they can play with
bubble rings and stuff.
It's just incredible.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
And that kind of
recreational freedive
is what most people do.
You can love freediving
and never compete.
Like me, for instance,
who will never compete.
But you can still
get a lot out of it.
We want to take questions.
But before that, I want
to talk just a few minutes
about marine plastic pollution.
And I brought little
props up here.
Last summer I did
a story on 5 Gyres.
5 Gyres is, I think, one of
the world leaders in fighting
marine plastic pollution.
They're a nonprofit based here
in Santa Monica, actually.
And I went on this voyage
through the North Atlantic
gyre-- which we went for
an expedition from Bahamas
to Bermuda.
And along the way
we were trolling
through some of the most
beautiful blue water
I've ever seen.
Trawling, excuse me.
And we have these little trawls.
Fine mesh trawls
that they designed.
And in the bluest
water I've ever seen--
and also on that voyage were
people like Kimi Werner,
who's a champion spear
fisherwoman and if you have
a chance to Google her
Kimi K-I-M-I Werner.
She's got amazing
footage online.
You'll see her riding the tail
fan of a great white shark,
among other amazing things.
And there were some pro surfers.
Jack Johnson as well.
A lot of these people have
seen some of the most beautiful
ocean scapes in the world.
And here we were in one of them.
None of us ever
seen bluer water,
and we would trawl
through the water
and we'd come up
with micro plastics.
You know, micro plastics.
Because everywhere in the
world now, every inch of ocean
has micro plastics.
Every inch of ocean.
And what 5 Gyres does is,
tries to study it, and then
raise awareness.
And the gyres are
these current systems.
There's five of
them in the world.
And they're giant
wind and water current
systems that take
all the garbage that
has been in rivers, whatever
dumped in the marine system,
however it is, and they
end up in these swirling
gyres at the surface.
And then they sink.
This plastic sinks.
And it breaks down.
Because plastic never goes away.
Metal, glass, paper, all
that stuff disintegrates.
Plastic never
disintegrates smaller
than these micro pieces.
They get eaten by fish.
Those fish get eaten
by bigger fish.
We eat the other fish, so it
gets into the food system.
They bioaccumulate
toxins in the water.
Then they sink to
deep sea sediment.
It's been found in
They get in under water
currents and distribute
all over the world.
It's been found in
Arctic ice cores.
I don't really want
to preach to heavy,
but I will say that it's in
my opinion the number two,
second only to climate
change, in terms
of environmental disasters
happening on this earth
right now.
It's completely man made.
And the only way to
stop it, is to stop
using single use plastic.
A better way is to stop
producing single use plastic.
Go into any grocery store,
Whole Foods included,
it's hard to find stuff
that's not wrapped in plastic.
It's really hard.
And that's that
single use plastic.
And there's no reason for it.
I have these little
things, these are nurdles.
This is what most
plastic comes--
that's the initial
compound of the plastic
that they use to make
bottles or anything else.
Nurdles.
And the other thing we should
know is 90% of single use
plastic cannot be recycled.
And even the non recycled stuff
get shipped to India and China
from here, often.
And gets sorted out.
And ends up in the
water systems out there.
And then ends up in
our marine environment.
So it's a really broken loop
system-- it's not a loop
system, it's a broken system.
And the only way is
to stop using it.
I encourage you to
look over there.
There are some 5
Gyres brochures.
And you can take a look at it.
5gyres.org is the organization.
The number five gyres dot org.
And I'll let you guys
look at these things, too.
It's something that's
really close to my heart,
as someone who loves the ocean,
and I think we can fix it.
And we will fix it.
And then 20, 30 years
after we fix it,
when archaeologists go
back and take ice cores,
they'll see all this
plastic, and they'll
be like, what were these guys
using so much plastic for?
This is like the Plasticine
age that we're in now.
Not to alarm you too
heavily, but it's true.
So here.
We'll leave these.
And you guys can ask
questions if you like.
BEN: Just briefly.
A tradition at the
Vertical Blue competition
is that one of the days
before the comp starts,
they will take everyone
out to the beach, which
is about a quarter of a
mile stretch of beach,
and do a beach cleanup.
And so everyone
gets garbage bags,
and you fill it up with as
much plastic as you can find.
And it's absolutely shocking.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
And Long Island is right
in the middle of that gyre.
We went by it, and it's
right in the middle.
So all this plastic
is getting washed up
on these beautiful
beaches, and it's not
being generated by Long Island.
It's generated offshore.
Or different islands.
Different places.
Mainland America, most likely.
BEN: So, yeah.
Particularly the single use
plastic water containers.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
That's why you see me slipping
out of this behemoth thing
and dripping all over myself.
Because that's an easy way.
There's easy fixes
that we can do.
I don't want to put it all on
the consumer, because really,
this product should
be phased out.
But obviously we can all
do better, myself included.
AUDIENCE: I was
curious about how
the sport translates-- we're
talking about elite athletes.
Can professional freedivers
also run a half marathon,
no problem?
Is their use of oxygen
just like someone
who is training at altitude?
I'm just curious on how it
translates to other sports.
BEN: It depends, somewhat,
on which disciplines
the athlete is focused on.
Some of them, more or less,
would translate differently.
For instance static apnea.
There are some people
that specialize just
in the pure breath hold.
And that's the
opposite of cardio.
And they've trained their
system to conserve energy,
rather than to burn it.
And so for them, it might not
translate into a long distance
run.
I think a lot of the athletes
do more weight training,
and they taper off the cardio
before they would really
do a freediving competition,
because the physical systems
used are much different.
But in general, the best
freedivers are in killer shape,
if you were to go and see them.
ADAM SKOLNICK: And will
often come from a swimming
background of some kind.
Alexey and Natalia
are perfect examples.
They were competitive
swimmers all their lives.
And then, in Natalia's case,
she tabled it for 20 years.
And in Alexi's
case, he went right
from swimming-- one of the
elite Russian youth swimmers.
And ended up being
a fin swimmer.
Which is this other sport
we don't really know about.
But there's actual people who
sprint with monofins in pools.
It's big in Europe, and
Eastern Europe especially.
And so he did that, and that
led him into this sport.
I think a lot of people
in competitive freediving
are interested-- what if
a guy like Michael Phelps
decided to start doing this?
And there are some
college swimmers
that have made progress.
Those guys though,
will still come up
against the same kind
of limiting factors
that any average
freediver might have.
Can I equalize below
a certain depth?
Are my lungs flexible enough?
It takes time to
get down to depth,
otherwise you can
injure your lungs.
So they'll bump up against
those same roadblocks
that will delay them,
even if they are athletic.
I think it's more likely that
a great athlete might also
do some freediving vs.
freedivers that will then
go on to do other sports.
And a good example
are big wave surfers.
So a lot of big wave surfers
now do apnea and breath hold
training.
And most freediving
instruction, PFI included,
and others will do surf safety
schools where they'll actually
work with big wave surfers
who might get two wave hold
downs or minute hold downs after
paddling for a minute, where
they're anaerobic and they still
have to relax, and endure it.
And so that's probably
the best correlation.
AUDIENCE: Is there
much crossover
from competitive
divers to people
who do recreational snorkeling?
I think the abilities
that you developed
would help, as a snorkeler,
give you more time or depth
to see more stuff?
[INAUDIBLE] surface.
BEN: Yes.
Absolutely.
That's a large part of why a lot
of freedivers do what they do,
is because they do love
the snorkeling aspect,
and just the recreational aspect
of getting out on the water,
and just looking around
or playing with fish
or dolphins or something.
You can interact with wildlife
a lot better as a freediver
than as a scuba diver,
because the bubbles tend
to scare the fish away and
you're not as maneuverable.
Yeah, doing it
recreationally is a big draw.
And I mean, for me,
personally, it certainly is.
I mean, the competitive
aspect is something
that I do to have an excuse
to go somewhere and be
able to freedive for a while.
It's just that there happens
to be a competition happening.
But really, I do it leaning more
towards the recreational end
of the spectrum.
And so it really is
advanced snorkeling, really.
ADAM SKOLNICK: And
for spear fisherman,
it's a vital tool as well.
Which is basically
what you're saying.
But sometimes in blue water.
BEN: Yeah, William
Trubridge is interesting.
He's pretty much a
vegan, except for fish
that he spears himself.
If he wants protein,
he's got to work for it.
AUDIENCE: On the
snorkeling thing.
I did do some PADI work with
a chap whose point of view
was, the nice thing about doing
freediving practice before you
go down with a tank, is that you
don't breathe very often when
you are on the tank, and it
doesn't scare the fish away.
So he used his
freediving as a way
of building up his tolerance,
so that he can just not
breathe for two minutes
while he's at depth
with a tank on his back.
Seemed a useful thing to learn.
The thing that I
mostly have trouble
with when I'm snorkeling,
trying to get down to depth,
because there is work that
I'm doing with a camera,
and I can't see a damn
thing without a mask.
Or at least not enough
to take a photo, anyway.
So are there any
recommendations for how
to handle the fact
that-- I end up
putting an awful lot of the air
that was in my lungs in my mask
in order to be able to still
not have water in my mask
and be able to see
for the camera.
I've seen low volume
masks, but they
don't seem to be particularly
low volume compared
to what my lungs are like
by the time I'm down there.
BEN: A lot of
competitive freedivers,
when they're doing particularly
deep dives, actually
transfer to using fluid goggles
instead of an air filled mask.
So the idea is you just
have regular swim goggles,
you put in very
thick lenses in them,
so that when you flood them
with saline, or with sea
water at depth, and you
can still see clearly.
And so that's one
way to go about that.
Some of the freediving
masks-- there's
one type of mask called
a Sphera that's common.
It's like $50.
It's a fairly cheap mask,
but it has plastic lenses.
It scratches if you breathe on
it, but it is very low volume,
and it's curved.
So it warps things a little
bit in your peripheral vision,
but it does squeeze right
onto your face as you go down,
and it uses very little
air to equalize it.
And so that's one a lot of
the competitive freedivers use
if they're doing medium depth.
And some divers have set
world records in masks.
Martin Stepanek did
120 something meters.
ADAM SKOLNICK: You just breathe
out your nose a little bit,
that's enough with a Sphera.
AUDIENCE: That was riveting.
A couple of questions.
One, you talk about the
danger when you're coming up,
but it seems like when you
are negatively buoyant,
it sounds like you don't have
the rescue divers down there,
either.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Right.
AUDIENCE: You're all on
your own to get back up.
Is that a problem?
Or do people typically
have enough experience not
to exhaust themselves.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Well it's not
a problem because of the way
physics works with pressure.
The way physics works is, as
you go down deeper and deeper,
your lungs are shrinking.
And so the brain feels like
you have plenty of oxygen.
Your partial pressure of
oxygen in your bloodstream
is actually up.
So with every atmosphere
of pressure that you add,
the partial pressure goes up.
And so your system
is like, OK, we
have plenty of oxygen.
We're going to be fine.
We're going to keep operating.
And then at the depth, when
they start coming back,
the reverse happens.
And the reason you wouldn't have
divers on tanks at that depth
is because, as you know, you
can get decompression sickness
if you are on a tank
and you're way deep.
So you wouldn't able to do
anything with that diver
anyway.
There are some competitions.
Deja Blue, which is run by
Performance Freediving that
does have tech divers on
tanks at those deep depths.
And they'll shake the line if
something horrible happens.
And there is the line, too.
If a safety diver goes
down to 30, 35 meters
and doesn't see
his diver coming,
and knows that the
diver is supposed
to come at a certain
time, because there's
a time estimate that they know,
then they can shake the line.
And the diver is attached
by lanyard to the line,
and they can pull the
diver out that way.
AUDIENCE: That answers
my second question of how
the heck do you navigate.
ADAM SKOLNICK: Yeah.
And there are issues like that.
In the book, I
talk about a diver
in the Caribbean competition
in 2014, his lanyard,
it wasn't a quick
release, often they
have quick release
Velcro lanyards that
can pull if it gets knotted.
And he gets knotted
at the bottom plate,
and can't get out.
And for a minute you don't
know what's going to happen.
And that happens.
And that's when you shake the
line, and you pull him up.
BEN: There was
one crazy incident
in a comp a few years ago, where
a diver went to go do a dive,
and on the way down, the lanyard
got disconnected from the line.
And so as he's falling down
towards the bottom plate,
he's drifting away from the
line, just off into the blue.
And at some point
realized that he was lost.
And started to turn around,
started trying to swim back up.
But he was a little
disoriented down there,
and was actually
swimming sideways,
and not making any
vertical progress at all.
And by sheer luck, managed to
swim into the next competition
line over, climb up that line
all the way to the surface,
and was in good enough shape
to get all the way to the top.
So yeah, if you come
unclipped, that's a problem.
ADAM SKOLNICK: It's a problem.
And it just shows
that with this sport,
there's already a very
thin margin for error.
Some people just lose
track of priorities.
I think Nick did
that towards the end.
And you can operate
where all of a sudden
there's no margin for error.
And that's what happened
also with Natalia, though.
So it's not just upstarts.
You know, Natalia is the
most decorated athlete ever,
and she also had it.
I think it's important for all
of us to look at our lives.
Where are we overvaluing,
and what are we overvaluing?
And try to maintain perspective.
That's a lesson for
everybody, I think.
BEN: Yeah.
Even if you try to
dive safely, if you
try to set up your dive so
that you say that there's
a 1% chance that something
will go seriously wrong,
if you do 100 dives,
chances are you're
going to hit that 1%
on one of the dives.
It's a reason to be--
ADAM SKOLNICK: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My question is about
recreational diving.
With scuba, say
I'm on a dive trip.
Your limiting factor is build
up of oxygen and nitrogen
in your blood.
So when you're
freediving on a trip,
assuming you're well within
what your comfort level is,
say 30 meter or whatever.
How many dives do
you do to that depth?
What's a regimen of a normal
recreational dive trip?
BEN: It depends on
your level of fitness.
There's a lot of
spear fisherman that
will go out and do 20, 30 of
those type of dives in a row.
Tank can probably answer
that question as a spearo.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ADAM SKOLNICK: Correct
me if I'm wrong, guys,
because I don't really
cover that in this,
but if you're in the
20 to 30 meter range,
you would have to do a lot of
dives to get the kind of bubble
build up in your blood like you
would if you're on air tank,
breathing at depth.
That's where decompression
sickness is much more likely.
I only saw decompression
sickness once
in the entire
research of this book,
and it was with a diver who
had done repeated 100 meter
plus dives, day after day.
It was last year.
And he did 100 meter plus,
day after day after day.
And so that build up of
that, is what gave him
some very minor decompression.
He didn't have to do
a chamber, or he maybe
did a day or two in
the chamber in Nassau,
and then he was completely fine.
So decompression
sickness can happen
if they're weighted
on sleds, and they
are going 200 plus meters,
or something like that.
Then it can happen.
But it's much more
common in breathing air.
That's why often
freedivers will say
it's actually more
dangerous and statistically
it is more dangerous to
be on a tank at depth,
than it is to be
off a tank at depth.
BEN: Because if you
need to go up quickly--
ADAM SKOLNICK: Because you can
go out quickly and you wont
hurt yourself.
BEN: But for
recreational diving,
even if you're diving
within your limits,
that assumes that every dive is
going to go according to plan.
And the problem
is, if you go down
and you get distracted
by something
and you're down
longer than you think,
and suddenly you realize I'm 50
feet down, and I'm out of air.
That's when trouble can happen.
It's so important to always
have somebody watching you,
when you're diving, who knows
how to do a rescue, and so on.
ADAM SKOLNICK: One up,
one down, they say.
And before we go, I just
wanted to say thank you.
I want to thank Google, because
writing is a team sport.
It seems like the most
solitary thing in the world,
but especially a
book like this where
it relies on so many
sources to be so open,
including these guys here.
Everyone here.
And obviously readers and book
stores, and that kind of thing.
But Google spending time doing
this, and inviting me here,
and having you guys
take your time.
That's right there with it.
And I really appreciate it.
I'm so grateful.
I know every author that
comes here must feel that way.
I certainly do, so I really want
to thank you guys for coming.
And if you want, I'll sign
some books over there.
And I'll have these little
plastic toys for you
to check out, if you want.
BEN: OK.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]